let's go back 1617
what was growing up some of your
personal
biggest challenges as a teenage lad yeah
in midlands
yeah right what was some of your biggest
challenges which are kind of some of the
things what drive you today
yeah what are they i think my challenges
i mean i wasn't good at
it academically so my teachers most of
my school teachers
kind of um wrote me off really
and i think was it because you wasn't
good or was it because you didn't try
i think he was both okay yeah i think it
was both i think i didn't try because
i knew i wasn't that good and in me in
fact that's one of the things in me
there was greatness
and because i knew i wasn't great
academically
i knew i wasn't going to be the best i
then thought
what's the point of even trying and then
i was just looked at as a loser
yeah well it's in me somewhere and i
think this is the case with so many when
i go to schools now
i've even gone back to my old yeah and
i've ran assemblies and stuff
and now when i see look at me now miss
but
they're great yeah i mean you can always
you can you can always get better and
focus on the few people every everybody
does yeah teachers genuinely care
yeah they don't earn a lot of money so
they wouldn't do what they do there
might be
one percent of teachers who couldn't do
anything else but most teachers could go
and get a different job and earn a lot
more money yeah
i think i just wasn't understood you
know but now when i go back to schools
and stuff and i see
that that that one kid who's kind of on
their own
uh maybe a bit a bit of a mischievous
short attention span i actually
sometimes see greatness in that kid
you have to yeah so i think that was a
struggle and then also um
i went to a very small christian school
and
we secondary uh all through from from
the age of six to 16. okay got you and
it was it was there was like literally a
hundred people in the whole school
wow yeah it was tiny and we wore
obviously different color uniform so
when i was coming home
i had like an hour and a half multiple
bus journeys and stuff to get home
i went to school in warsaw and
the kids the other school kids would
pick on me because i know the area well
you know i've done quite a lot of
schools and okay
they'd pick on me because i wore a
different color uniform
which i actually used to enjoy because i
enjoyed fighting so i used to almost
like everyone else in my school would
take their blazers off
take their tie off and walk home i would
make a thing of
wearing my blazer because i almost like
where does that come from
i think it was the only thing i was good
at in school i was i was i was i was um
i was good in that setting i was like i
can fight and i can whereas academically
i'm not good so i thought well actually
it was something yeah which one i was
good at
interesting what was your parents
thoughts about your relationship with
school so my parents split up when i was
seven okay
and how did that affect you yeah it
wasn't a good speech my parents split up
around the same time it wasn't a good
split up
because you know they were cussing each
other out and stuff my dad for years for
saying
was they using you as well like no but i
don't i wouldn't like to say bad stuff
about yeah i mean listen i love my mom i
love my dad to bits
but it was it was i'll just say it was
it was a difficult time it was a nasty
split up
and um what did they think my dad didn't
really get involved at all
with with school i used to see him
regularly my mom
would almost side with me and we'd just
be like oh you know
she they i remember there was one school
teacher who called my mom in and said
that i was dealing drugs
in the school i wasn't selling drugs
what i was doing is i was selling little
magic tricks
i was buying them off my dad's market
because he was he was a magician he had
a market
and i was buying them off my dad
wholesale and then i was selling them
retail
to my mates at school but the teachers
were like i think he's selling drugs
so um they called my mom in but she was
like no he's not selling drugs
um i don't think he is anywhere
even even the um the banks thought i was
selling drugs i used to um
i had a lot of paper ants i used to make
a lot of money doing entrepreneurial
stuff how old was you around then like
15.
15. so okay so you was quite not
money-driven but you
i was good at it you controlled certain
things you feel like okay i'm not so
good in school but i can control this
area i want freedom i want money and i
want to do what i want to do
um and you said you was good at it so
you did more of that type of thing yeah
exactly but then the banks
asked me direct sat me down where are
you getting this money from
i said oh i'm washing cars i'm selling
magic tricks i'm doing paper
and they're like drugs i know i've no
i've never i've never taken
or sold drugs um but yeah it was it's
just
it's just an interest in being an
entrepreneur
in school i think that schools and this
would be an interesting one to see what
you think because
the education system does not teach
money no no it's not in there
and not only that but the whole message
around money and business i didn't even
know what it
was i didn't even know what and my mom
and dad are both entrepreneurial they're
self-employed i thought you either
worked for someone or you worked for
yourself
i never understood the idea of being a
business owner and having staff or being
an investor and getting passive income
like that was something
completely foreign to me and it was not
in school so
a kid that's naturally got that
entrepreneurial flair
i feel like needs to be encouraged in
schools rather than it being clamped out
schools often teach compliance
rather than thinking outside the box so
i'm really passionate about schools and
that's why i respect what you do
and i think from my experience it all
depends on the school
yeah all depends on the trust who owns
the school what their values are it does
what the curriculum
and what they're trying to do but there
are some schools who have put money and
funding behind students going out and
trying to learn different things and
they would probably want to teach more
money but at the same time it comes from
top down right offstead it comes down to
so many restrictions yeah but
that's the thing though here's the thing
of course it depends on the score and
and there's a lot of amazing teachers
out there and amazing schools out there
but the you can't have it in the
curriculum like you say offstead on that
so you're almost banned from teaching
that's exactly it and i think that it's
ludicrous
that you would teach people what do you
learn in school in school you learn how
to get good grades to then get a good
job
and what's the point of a job to get
money well why not just skip all that
and teach them money straight yeah
to be fair i do talk a bit qui quite a
lot about money so you can just go into
any classroom i know what do you where
do you want to be in 10 years
yeah yeah so i want to be rich i want to
be rich but it's like okay what are you
doing today what
what what's happening and see the drop
but that the drive's there right there
yeah just kids what do you want to do i
want to be a famous youtuber i want to
be rich i want to be a businessman
but there is a difference all right so
they got those expectations yeah
and then they've got they got champions
league expectations but then they got
sunday league work ethic planning and
preparation
so then there wasn't if they're 15 16
they're still not going out doing
what you was doing when you was 15 16.
so sometimes we got to teach them the
tools and the strategies yeah
and the work ethic still because as you
know for a fact you ain't gonna just
walk into millions you're not gonna just
walk into a house like this it takes
time it takes
effort and you've been doing it for 15
odd years at least
kind of creating you the character
everything you need the work ethic the
consistency so that that's the
trick some of them yes you've got people
like yourself you're putting in the work
they're young and you can see
it but then you've got others who want
they want more for doing less
yeah and it's for me my biggest
challenge especially my job is trying to
show them
he's this your expectations this is what
you're doing there's a disconnect
how can we bring that together yeah i
mean i think that you say to the kid
what do you want to achieve in life
what's your dreams i want to be rich i
want this i want that great
how are you going to get there um how
are you going to
what's the plan yeah i've got here and
then and then in part of that plan work
out a plan and any part of that plan is
going to be okay well we need to work
hard we need to graft we need to
we need to fix we need to add value what
is set why is setting goals and a plan
important well setting goals on the plan
is important because it's like trying to
play football without knowing that you
need to without without knowing the
objective of the game if you
if you don't know that you need to keep
the ball in the net you just run around
there and that's what people do
that's what that was me at school yeah
people people just run around
aimlessly you need to have a goal
um i like that
because that's one just i said i always
talk about you can't be disciplined if
you do not have a plan
and it's all about goal setting i say
you never want to be one of these adults
who spend more time planning a holiday
when they do their own lives that's
right that's
nearly everybody literally i'm planning
a wedding but not planning a marriage oh
explain so people spend more time wow
planning the wedding then they do plan
the actual marriage
i.e the relationship how things are
gonna go wow
that's strong you used that one before
right
dude maybe i don't i don't recall ever
ever
ever saying that before dive into that
more please actually just dive into that
whole concept a bit more because i think
it's so important
because i got married about two years
ago and it's true the amount of effort
and everything that goes into just
getting married
um while the wedding you don't really
think about after i think it's about i
think it's also about
what expectations of what people think
and what people care about
people care about your wedding day
everyone wants oh nice wedding day
because that's other people
but actually it's about saying what how
do i create my life
yeah and i think people spend their
whole lives trying to be
liked trying to be liked trying to
please their parents trying to please
people
actually saying what what are the
fundamentals for me and that's not
selfish because if
you're only able to help people if
you're coming if you help yourself first
and i think that planning the wedding
day it's about perceptions it's about
people think it's about
the photographs it's about all this
stuff and people plan the wedding day
but don't plan
the actual marriage you know and it's
the same with
everything people planned the baby
shower rather than the actual
and the christmas maybe rather than how
to bring up the kid
that's fascinating what has been them
creating your training programs
cr building your property portfolio what
has been some of the biggest challenges
you have faced
on that process are you talking just
strictly my training company or
uh business in general just throughout
your life because you're 29 years
now say when you first started say you
got out of school
what are some of the biggest challenges
you've faced yeah trying to do your own
thing
i i think probably the biggest
challenges i've found there's been so
many
um uh having to have patience that
sometimes there are things that just do
take time
yeah and sometimes that is part of the
process if if you've got to go from
here to edinburgh in the car it's a nine
hour journey
that's it and in the same way you want
to lose weight i like that it's a
journey you want to become a millionaire
it's a journey and as entrepreneurs we
want things fast
so i think that for me is sometimes a
challenge because one thing's
immediately
but it's about having and that's a good
thing being impatient is a good thing
as long as um you're aware of it and you
use it as a good thing so i think that's
one thing i think another thing is
um being misunderstood
um it's very easy as an entrepreneur i
think you're massively misunderstood as
well
um from everything i've seen that's why
i wanted this interview today as well
is because people criticize you a lot
but all you do is keep bouncing back
yeah you keep coming back you're so
resilient and you don't give
you you don't give to people the time of
day or the energy they want
and you use it to your advantage i think
that's absolutely
unreal right because a teenager might
not get enough likes on their picture so
they did
delete it yeah right somebody might
start want to start a business but they
care what their mom thinks so they're
not going to do it
right and then here's people who are
actively trying to go out and destroy
you
and you just use it like it's like
adding fuel to the fire
yeah and you just keep bouncing back
bouncing back and i have to admire it
right
i just think it's absolutely insane how
where does that come from right
where does that come from because
sometimes people are going to take it
personal
but it doesn't seem like you do it's
like you can disconnect it yeah and keep
moving forward where does that come from
i think all my life i've been
misunderstood right going back to at
school
and i'm quite you i'm quite okay with
that and i'm also quite okay not being
liked as well
okay most people are gonna go back to
the wedding day why do they prepare for
the wedding but not the marriages
because the wedding day everyone
everyone can see that and and it's for
other people you're popular yeah they
want to be popular i want to be liked
um and even in my training business
i can't i care about the goal so my
training company the goal
is to see people's lives and finances to
revolutionize that's the goal
the goal is not for me to be liked so i
think it's just staying focused and
pressed on for the goals of my faith as
well i've got strong faith and i think
for me that's also
really really important and fundamental
but yeah i do bounce back and
not even bounce back because i don't
even i don't even feel like i've got
knocked down i'm just like
i know it's it's it's water off a duck's
back
for me it's just it just bounces off me
i don't bounce that that bounces he just
bounces off me is that 100 real though
that's 100 real because i'll be honest
if if i had as much sometimes kristen
you've got
i'm quite sensitive yeah despite my
upbringing despite
being kind of quite rough when i was
little i love fighting as well but i'm
still quite sensitive yeah
um nah nah you asked my wife i'm very
very cool and it does not it's amazing
it doesn't
i mean listen does it ever does it ever
like
there's a line sometimes if people are
really overstep the line there's a line
you know where things are really unjust
or it's like that's really not right
people bringing my family into stuff and
that's not cool but
getting criticized and stuff online is
is just part
of it process that's part of the process
yeah you can't take the heat you better
get out of the kitchen
and that's it so and especially here's
the thing right
cam i'm trying to change the way people
think
i'm trying to open people up into a
whole new world of thinking around
finance and around what they can achieve
there's not one person in the whole of
history that's changed the way people
think
on the planet that has not been
ridiculed
wow it just isn't explain
well i mean you name one person that's
that's left the world better than they
found it that's
a legend that's i mean you name one
person gandhi
um martin luther king jesus i mean they
crucified jesus
so how can you expect to be a pioneer
for something be a business leader
and and be changing the way people think
and not be ridiculed
it's just it's not gonna happen that's
crazy